[Música]
más de 30 muertos deja un atentado
suicida contra una mezquita de mayoría
chiita en afganistán el hecho ocurre
justamente cuando se cumplen dos meses
de la caída de kabul a manos del talibán
francia rinde homenaje hoy al profesor
samuel para ti asesinado por un hija
vista por mostrar en su clase
caricaturas del profeta mahoma mañana se
cumplirá un año de su partida tenemos
información desde parís
entra en vigor en italia el llamado fase
verde donde sin vacuna o test negativo
de kobe 19 no se puede trabajar una de
las normas contra la pandemia más
estrictas del mundo cerca del 10 por
ciento de los trabajadores italianos no
se han vacunado y muchos protestan por
tener que pagar la prueba que cuesta 15
euros vamos hasta rojo
muy buen día para todos gracias por
continuar en francés 24 comenzamos al
menos 33 personas murieron y 65
resultaron heridas a tras una explosión
en una mezquita de minoría chiita
durante las oraciones del viernes en el
sur de afganistán el hecho ocurre una
semana después de que un atentado
similar en otro templo causará 80
muertos y más de un centenar de heridos
veamos más en el siguiente informe de
alva santana
nuevo episodio de violencia en
afganistán tras un ataque suicida en
kandahar en el sur del país con varias
explosiones en una mezquita chiita
durante la hora del tradicional rezo de
los viernes
los disparos empezaron después de
terminar las oraciones luego se
produjeron dos o tres explosiones nos
lanzaron contra una ventana muchas
personas martirizadas o heridas estaban
allí tiradas no sé qué pasó después
este episodio se da una semana después
de un ataque similar en la región
norteña de kunduz contra una mezquita
también chiíta que dejó al menos 80
muertos y cerca de un centenar de
heridos
reivindicado por el grupo terrorista
estado islámico
ahora el golpe es contra khan dar el
corazón religioso de los talibanes en lo
que parece una acción contra el nuevo
gobierno justo el mismo día que se
cumplen dos meses desde la llegada de
los talibanes al poder el conflicto
entre la facción talibán y la filial
afgana del estado islámico está en
activo desde 2015 y es un reto más para
el ejecutivo que en estos momentos está
luchando por el reconocimiento
internacional además del repunte de la
violencia en todo el país afganistán
enfrenta una creciente crisis política
sanitaria y económica que pone en riesgo
de pobreza y hambre a millones de
personas y el líbano comenzaron los
funerales de las seis personas
fallecidas ayer en el tiroteo que se
registró en medio de las manifestaciones
convocadas por hezbollah en rechazo al
juez que investiga la explosión en el
puerto de beirut en agosto 2020 que dejó
más de 200 muertos los simpatizantes de
hezbollah piden que se cambie el
magistrado ya que lo señalan de
parcialidad
y las escuelas de toda francia rindieron
homenaje al profesor samuel para ti ya
que mañana se cumple un año de su
asesinato por parte de un yihadista para
ti un profesor de historia y geografía
fue salvajemente atacado por un
refugiado checheno días antes de su
asesinato del profesor mostró
caricaturas del profeta mahoma a sus
estudiantes durante una clase quería que
reflexionarán la libertad de expresión
en uno de los homenajes participa el
ministro de educación desde allí nos
reportó nuestra periodista en parís
natalia risk
bueno pues nada homenaje es bastante
emotivos bastante sentidos uno de ellos
que se realizó aquí en este liceo ronda
la fontaine al oeste de la capital y yo
que ustedes ven a mis espaldas y
justamente durante estas conmemoraciones
pues estuvo presente el bloque a quienes
el ministro de educación de francia tuvo
tiempo de hablar con los alumnos de una
clase historia geografía saber en que
habían trabajado en estos últimos días
ellos e incluso van a hacer un
documental o web acerca de la democracia
de la libertad ahí tuvo el tiempo para
hablar con ellos para reiterarles la
importancia de defender la laicidad que
para él pues él explicaba que es lo que
nos permite a todos vivir en una en una
sociedad libre en una sociedad donde
estemos unidos a pesar de que no se
piensen y se crean las mismas cosas
luego de esto en el auditorio de este
colegio pues hubo este minuto de
silencio bastante emotivo y también la
coral del colegio que interpretó una
canción que escribió
vívelo para ti así que homenajes como
estos fueron los que se realizaron a lo
largo de toda esta jornada y el ministro
también explicó que lo que quería sobre
todo era que esto no fuera un homenaje
de un solo día sino que fuera algo
perenne y de hecho por eso hay varios
colegios y espacios públicos en todo el
país que a partir de hoy están siendo
bautizado samba pa ti de hecho mañana
una plaza frente a la universidad de la
sorbona pues será inaugurada con ese
nombre también en francia el presidente
manuel macrón preside un homenaje
nacional en honor a ver german un
soldado francés quien combatió durante
la segunda guerra mundial como parte de
las fuerzas francesas de liberación y
falleció a los 101 años de edad del 12
de octubre german es considerable último
compañero de la liberación y será
enterrado en la cripta del memorial de
la francia combatiente en normalizarían
cerca de parís este próximo 11 de
noviembre german fue hijo de un oficial
general de las tropas coloniales quien
se alistó en a fuerzas francesas libres
a la edad de los 19 años
[Música]
la policía de noruega solicito que
permanezca detenido el sospechoso de los
ataques con arco flecha y otras armas
que dejó cinco muertos el miércoles en
la pequeña ciudad de cons ver que el
hombre de 37 años admitió ser este autor
del atentado que la policía investiga
como un acto terrorista deberá
permanecer en aislamiento por cuatro
semanas mientras hay un veredicto
vamos ahora reino unido porque el
diputado david ms fue atacado con un
cuchillo en essex en el sur de
inglaterra el atacante fue arrestado por
la policía el legislador lleva 38 años
en el parlamento y es conocido por su
postura de derecha en el pasado ha hecho
comentarios en contra de la comunidad
lgtb
a partir de hoy en italia entra en vigor
el pase sanitario bautizado pase de
verde en los lugares de trabajo es decir
una prueba negativa de kobe 19 o de
vacunación es necesaria el país se
enfrenta a la amenaza de protestas y
huelgas masivas a pesar de que tanto la
vacunación como la exigencia del
documento en sí tiene una gran
popularidad en ese país europeo que fue
epicentro de la pandemia en el año 2020
es una tasa de vacunación con la que
muchos países sueñan más del 86 por
ciento de los italianos han recibido al
menos una inyección contra el hobbit 19
así que para la mayoría de los
trabajadores presentar la prueba de
vacunación o un test negativo ahora
obligatorios será una mera formalidad
todos mis trabajadores y yo estamos
vacunados pero por interés personal no
por política ni nada parecido
exigido desde junio para lugares de ocio
y ahora ampliado a todos los
trabajadores del sector privado y
público el conocido como pase verde es
una medida con respaldo popular los
sondeos muestran que todos década
italianos están a favor en un país que
se vio muy afectado durante los primeros
meses de la pandemia
en una empresa tan grande como esta es
probablemente una de las principales
cosas que nos protege a todos estoy
definitivamente a favor de ello creo sin
embargo italia enfrenta protestas por la
medida los trabajadores de los
principales puertos amenazan con huelgas
indefinidas a pesar de que a muchos se
les han ofrecido pruebas gratuitas de
kobe 19 para obtener el código qr
necesario las huelgas prolongadas o los
bloqueos violentos podrían generar
problemas en un sector ya escaso de
personal o causar retrasos en la entrega
de mercancías en toda italia por lo que
los estibadores y camioneros podrían
utilizar el pase sanitario para hacer
presión política importo viene el puerto
se utiliza para otros fines sin tener en
cuenta el daño que hace a sus familias
no pensando al daño que cargan el oro
familia el pasado fin de semana las
protestas contra el paso y sanitario ya
desataron violencia en roma después de
que militantes de extrema derecha
a los 10 mil manifestantes estos
violentos disturbios han llevado a pedir
la prohibición de los grupos
neofascistas en italia y es que más
temprano nuestra corresponsal en roma
natalia mendoza nos explicaba las
sanciones que pueden enfrentar los
trabajadores italianos si no presentan
el pase de verde
pues es cierto que hay fuertes sanciones
previstas para quienes no respeten esta
obligación quienes no presenten este
certificado sanitario no podrán trabajar
esto será considerado como una ausencia
injustificada la consecuencia será la
suspensión del salario y se exponen a
una sanción administrativa que varía
entre 600 y 1.500 euros el control de
este certificado sanitario será
responsabilidad del empleador quienes no
estén vacunados podrán presentar un test
en negativo un examen negativo de
coronavirus realizado 48 horas antes
pero los costos de este examen los
tendrá que asumir el trabajador vamos
ahora eeuu porque en texas se mantiene
en pie la prohibición del aborto en casi
todos los casos e incluso el de
violación o incesto después de que una
corte federal de apelaciones rechazara
el intento más reciente del gobierno del
presidente joe biden por revertir esta
ley la medida ha generado protestas
castiga a los abortos una vez que se
detecta actividad cardíaca en el embrión
sucede aproximadamente a las 6 semanas
de gestación antes de que incluso las
mujeres sepan que están embarazadas
y seguimos en eeuu porque el ex
presidente bill clinton está mejorando
según afirmó un vocero del hospital
donde permanece internado desde la noche
del día martes en california clinton de
75 años presentó una infección sanguínea
ha recibido tratamiento antibiótico y
también de fluidos mientras su salud
continúa siendo monitoreada los galenos
descartaron que se trata de con 19
clinton fue presidente desde 1993 hasta
el año 2001
y más de 160 grupos de activistas buscan
a los desaparecidos en méxico según
información oficial la cifra ha crecido
más del 20 por ciento y llega ya a los
100.000 las familias no pierden la
esperanza de encontrarlos con vida
informe andrew serán ha dicho una
búsqueda que no cesa hace siete años
tranquilina busca a su hija que
desapareció una tarde de septiembre en
cuernavaca capital del estado de morelos
en mexico
no sé yo sueño con abrazarla besarla
escuchar su voz tranquilino hace parte
de uno de los 160 colectivos repartidos
por todo méxico dedicados a la búsqueda
de desaparecidos es muy duro pensar en
un féretro en que ya no voy a ver su
sonrisa en que ya no vaya a ver sus ojos
pero a final de cuentas tengo pero tengo
mucha fe que la voy a encontrar y la
pongo en las manos de dios y pues que me
la mande como como él quiera con uno
como este mi bebé pero que pero yo
necesito saber que puede ella con sólo
dos millones de habitantes morelos es
relativamente pequeño pero está rodeado
de estados que han luchado contra la
violencia el 90 por ciento de los
crímenes que el público es justamente
para tratar de evitar estas situaciones
pero la verdad es que si es algo que nos
ha rebasado esta es plenamente de peso
pleno y visto a todas luces pero pero si
nosotros como autoridades hemos estado
haciendo pues lo propio lo propio que un
municipio puede ofrecerle en méxico
según la comisión nacional de búsqueda
las desapariciones llegan a las 93 mil
desde que iniciaron los registros 1964
en el último año la cifra de
desaparecidos ha crecido más del 20% la
violencia que azota el país hace más de
una década es ocasionada por la guerra
de los cárteles de la droga los
gobiernos anteriores incluido el de
andrés manuel lópez obrador han
intentado combatir las mafias sin éxito
pasamos ahora a francia porque en ese
país gradualmente se está eliminando la
venta de etiquetas de papel en el metro
de parís para ser reemplazados
completamente por tarjetas electrónicas
que permitirán al usuario comprar
boletos individuales para los fanáticos
de estos billetes se trata del final de
una era
[Música]
un final anunciado para los tiquetes de
papel del metro de parís poco a poco se
han ido eliminando para que sólo quede
la tarjeta electrónica navigo y
es gracioso porque mi novio se la pasó
haciendo rayitas con los tiquetes y
ahora le molesta que no podrá ser más
ranas
cambiaron las décadas y también lo
hicieron los boletos del metro antes de
que se introdujera en los torniquetes
automáticos los billetes serán revisados
por agentes que los perforaban se
aseguraban de que nadie intentara
colarse en una estación los que intentan
pasar sin pagar siempre nos cuentan
historias poco creíbles pero nosotros no
somos tan malos
antes era imposible subir al metro sin
el tiquete perforado conociera
perforadora de boletos en una de las
estaciones la verdadera con la
perforadora en mano y su sombrero pero
este trabajo desapareció gradualmente en
la década de 1970 a favor de los
torniquetes que validaban
automáticamente los boletos del metro
los nuevos tiquetes tienen una franja
magnética lo muestran e hicieron más
rápido y fácil el uso del transporte
público con una campaña publicitaria en
la década de 1980 la autoridad de
tránsito introdujo boletos de colores
[Música]
pero la llegada de la tarjeta
electrónica navego en el año 2000 marcó
un nuevo capítulo ahora la próxima
revolución está en marcha pues los
usuarios pueden comprar boletos
directamente en sus teléfonos móviles
y cientos de estudiantes en australia
faltaron a clases el viernes para exigir
acciones contra el cambio climático de
cara a la cumbre con 26 la huelga
estudiantil contra el clima marchó por
las calles de todo el país para pedir
que la nación oceánica que es uno de los
mayores emisores de gases de efecto
invernadero per cápita se sume a las
iniciativas mundiales para lograr
emisiones cero para el año 2050 a lo que
el gobierno se ha negado sin embargo el
primer ministro de scott morrison
anunció tras la presión ejercida que
asistirá a esta cumbre de la onu en
glasgow
hasta aquí el informativo